you think Nate would would take that hit
on his legacy to lose to a YouTuber
not a chance if you know anything about
the Diaz brothers there's not a any
amount of money that you could offer
them where they're going to take a fall
in a fight against a YouTuber you're out
of your mind this is the real deal man
you guys got to quit with that stuff
it's a huge test for Jake because the
volume of Nate the chin of Nate before
you finally understand I was like I
don't like the the Nate Diaz fight for
Jake's terrible idea he fought Anderson
looked good showed some boxing IQ you
know was in there he got hurt he came
back he dropped the Henderson Silva I
was like oh they might be Nate's gonna
be some trouble you can't watch that if
I think that Nate's not in trouble they
see the time you Fury fight like okay is
this a good fight